well it's time for another movie review
yeah it's like a review and a
recommendation yeah I think over the
past was it maybe three months I've
probably mentioned this movie two or
three times I'm two on different
occasions and I think it's now now it's
about time we actually properly address
blade bar 20:49 yes all right we don't
do a lot of newer movies but this was
actually one that made a big impression
on us when we saw it in the theater when
it came out and we recently just bought
it on blu-ray
yeah and rewatched it the second time
through yeah and it holds up on multiple
viewings yeah and actually the second
time I watched it like I got a lot
deeper richer experience at it because I
noticed a lot of things that I hadn't
noticed the first time and stuff like
that so let's now you probably remember
I mean I saw the original Blade Runner
yeah a long time I saw it when it came
out yeah and I haven't really seen it
for many many years
mmm it must be said Blade Runner 2049
you don't really have to have seen the
original to follow the story of this one
yeah but it helps it helps and you helps
build the passion for this movie
right like you see familiar but I'm just
saying if you're coming into a cult if
you've never seen the original Blade
Runner which I don't know why you
wouldn't because what's the matter with
you but if you haven't you won't be lost
you will be able to follow the story
yeah and for certain types of people you
know the ad degeneration Blade Runner 1
& 2 is probably gonna seem kind of slow
because the way movies are today is that
they're pretty much empty spectacles
they're kind of like rides at Disneyland
you sit in the theater and you go on
this big ride you don't know what
happened they go boy that was fun what
was that all about
at the end Blade Runner really isn't
like that it's more like an old
detective flick saying the actor istic
setting and honestly that his movie
takes his time it's almost like it's
like a mood piece or like an heirloom it
is a very it's not an action movie it's
I mean it's there's action in it there's
action in it it's obviously sci-fi but
it's actually it's really an art film
yeah it's taking his time and it's to
build character to build mood
and it's taking its time to really kind
of draw you into this world yet that the
characters live in that's the great
thing about it that's what that's what
makes this movie stand out from the
average garbage that they're making
nowadays yeah in terms of blockbusters
this is like the anti blockbuster even
though it had a blockbuster budget yeah
it was expensive it was very and it
looks great
it looks looks great beautiful the
writing is very good in it especially by
today's standards the writing is very
good yeah this is a proper science
fiction yeah the two guys that were the
truth two screenwriters one of them was
one of the who wrote the original Blade
Runner and the other one was one of the
writers on alien covenant so this is
very obviously wasn't directed by Ridley
Scott it was directed by Denis
Villeneuve who is kind of known for
doing arty sci-fi he did arrival he did
some other ones like that but like I
said this is very much an art film and
if you like the original Blade Runner
the what the coolest things about this
is that yes in a way it's a sequel yeah
but it's almost like it's not a rehash
no it almost kind of like it deepens the
questions it deepens the mysteries it
expands upon the original themes yeah in
the original movie and it looks exactly
like the world would look 30 years later
yeah now the world of Blade Runner is
the same world as alien 1 alien 2
Prometheus and alien covenant and it
also asks many of the same questions
that the movies I just mentioned ask
yeah I actually like all those movies
you know the Prometheus and alien
covenant some people didn't like them
but I on my blu-ray of access don't
Prometheus on blu-ray and I've watched
all the extra stuff and of course I was
geeking out about for me just when it
first came out I remember I looked at
all different angles that movie does
make sense but it takes time to figure
it out and you have to kind of know
other movies you know later yeah it's a
kind of a whole expanded universe yeah
and yeah and like the additional stuff
that was on the blu-ray helps you if you
were to actually read this
script for Prometheus it makes a lot
more sense you can read the script and
what makes a difference in the script of
Prometheus is that in the script it's
written what it is that David is reading
inside the alien temple and Prometheus
and if you can actually read what he's
reading things make a lot more sense of
that movie but maybe we'll talk about
that
yeah well the same world and basically
the question is what is it mean to be
human what is a human yeah and you know
exploring you know things with
Prometheus and alien covenant and things
like that they're kind of more exploring
it from an alien point of view like what
if aliens made you know a thing or what
if humans became godlike and things yet
nature whereas Blade Runner is more like
where is the line between a synthetic
human and a real human yeah you know it
is there really any difference and when
you get to a certain point yeah and is
AI life that's another question that's
the exam yes are artificial AI Holograms
are they real people or not yeah
or it doesn't matter does it get to a
point where it matter where you get to
the point where it's like does it even
matter anymore whether they think
they're real or you know do they have
dreams or ambitions or running like that
if they think they do
right then essentially they're just like
a human right now today's show we're not
gonna do any spoilers because this is
out of respect for our audience and this
is a newer movie and I know a lot all
right not I've seen it a lot of people
did not see this in the theater it
didn't do all that well the box office
well it made money but not as much as
they were as that year right it made
nowhere near what Star Wars made and
this blows the last Jedi out of the
water I mean this I mean it made up for
the disappointment of Star Wars in that
year well I think the problem was I mean
this movie was very anticipated it got
pretty much Universal critical acclaim
yeah it's won all kind of awards pretty
much deserved it it does
yeah and I'm not saying and I'm and I'm
not thinking I'm not saying I don't
think our wars did but this one did
right behind him yes seriously I'm so
sick it's like I'm so right okay so but
this movie I'm not saying it was not
overhyped at all it was actually much
much better than I was expecting
the thing is it's not like I said it's
not an action flick it's not it's very
long it's almost three hours and I know
that some people can't sit through that
maybe but you know it's like a visual
poem really yeah I think the lay it's
very philosophical I think the the
complaints about the length if you ask
me are [ __ ] well I think they're
both I enjoyed every minute of a
sickness I did do excellent and watching
it again on blu-ray it actually felt a
lot shorter
yeah like well of course it's this long
because that's how long it takes yes no
because I don't really feel like and I
think that's really the only minor
criticism I saw like of the very minor
criticism episode oh it could have been
length rule of a shorter but I did not
think yeah the rate of the length of
adds to the atmosphere and the feel ya
feel the kind of realism and immersion
that you get from watch that is a very
good it is very impressive immersive and
even I mean when you saw it in the
theater the whole thing the visuals the
score oh I love the score of this mix
not really music per se it's just kind
of like yeah kind of noise and it's like
and it really fits in with the whole
world and everything like that feel new
emotions you really feel like you're in
it I mean when we saw it in the theater
I was just kind of sitting there in my
seat with my mouth hanging open you know
like three hours yeah we saw an IMAX 3d
if I remember correct wasn't it yeah
okay and I was just when they showed
that city for the first time how big LA
was and yeah it was mind-blowing
yeah I was like you're yeah there's no
way to describe it just it was just uh
intimidating yeah how big it was and
then when you see what how these people
are living it kind of becomes clear why
they're all trying to get off world and
all the stuff that was happening in
alien 1 and alien to you
corporations ran everything that you
know there weren't the nation-states
didn't matter the environment and the
earth is pretty much used up everybody's
trying to get out of there
yeah the future isn't on the earth the
futures on these other world because
everything is pretty much polluted it's
totally polluted and just used up yeah
just used up there's this huge garbage
dump quality of life is bad yeah it's
like there's everyone's packed to these
little over knowing in LA yeah things of
that nature so you know they're trying
to use solar power but there really
isn't a Sun yeah everything's great
right and stuff like that it's
interesting too because like I said we
just bought it on blu-ray we watched it
again probably two nights ago yeah and
the second time I watched it and I got
this impression when I saw in the
theater too but the second time I
watched it was a lot more clear is how
sad this movies verse is so sad hopeful
in a way in a weird way how like it's
almost kind of a Victorian what do they
call that like that would they call when
you sat in a color Oh what do you call
that happy and sad at the same time but
yeah so let's actually kind of go into a
little bit about the plot but we won't
spoil anything like I said cuz I know
that was like before this movie came out
because you know how critically your big
credits get to see it before what I
remember what it was when it's just a
melancholy it was kind of a mellow well
that was the word I was thinking and I
don't think that was the word you were
talking okay yeah but yeah it's kind of
hopeful at the end but yeah it is it is
ultimately a very sad story in the first
movie you had a company called the
Tyrell corporation and it was making
something called a replicant and for
those of you don't know what a replicant
is a replicant was an artificial human
beings made out of genetically
engineered body parts they didn't live
long they were immensely strong you
could use him as slave labor they only
live for I think was four years or five
years I can't really remember they had
artificial memories they had memory
implants yeah
and that's what helps then that's what
helped a replicant I guess live a lot of
the rounds didn't weren't really she
didn't know they were replicants was one
of the things I think some of them did
no but they kind of emotionally kind of
leaned on their artificial memories to
get them through so and I think actually
in Blade Runner 2049 the woman that
makes the memories she actually says
something that the reason they give them
these implanted realistic memories is
because the more realistic memories they
have the more realistic their human
responses are yes right so that's why
they yeah and I guess also that kind of
adds to you can control them a little
better if they have normal human
responses that's part of it but
obviously at first yeah obviously in the
first Blade Runner the replicants they
went wrong it went rogue and yeah like
that so it would send out these blade
runner's job which was like a cop or a
detective and he just find out who was
an artificial human and they terminate
him they would retire yeah
now evidently the Nexus 6 generation
from the first movie there they're now
illegal you know you can't have them
anymore but Tyrell corporation went
bankrupt and a new corporation kind of
bought the rights to the Wallace
corporation redblock Tyrell and the new
Wallace corporations their new
replicants are a lot better I don't
remember which Nexus level think about
Nexus ain't I think they were a lot
safer more realistic and they were legal
to have and yeah they're supposed to be
much more submissive right yeah they
made a mo more obedient so the the main
story is about a nexus a replicant who
is a Blade Runner who's going out and
he's hunting the old Nexus yes model his
name is Kay and he's Ryan guy yeah
that's kind of what started thats where
the story starts off he's out retiring
an old Nexus I think was a Nexus 7 or
something and Sapir Martin and yeah and
all he was on that mission he found some
clues that lead him to some pretty
surprising discovery that PI what we
shouldn't talk about in the scope of
this recommendation
yeah for this movie but it's yeah
miracle happened
yes the discovery he made is so
monumental that animist in the PS as his
boss says
I was played by Robin Wright she says
this breaks the world right we can't
have that they can't let this out of the
bag right what they discovered and and
we prize shouldn't talk about that but
anyway he gets caught up in this big
complicated mission and with him he
takes his girlfriend on this mission and
his girlfriend is actually a hologram
her name is joy named joy also made by
the Wallace corporation yeah when you
watch them you're not really sure
whether or not joy is a real person or
not she's definitely a hologram but but
you don't know if she's less real than
okay okay so see that's kind of the
coolest thing because they have this
kind of parallel thing going on where
you have replicants versus humans and
then you also have a replicant who has a
companion or the hologram right and the
other replicas kind of looked down on
you if you're a replicant and your
girlfriend is a hologram yeah oh that's
not a real girl even though she is very
real yeah real yeah gets to the point
where it doesn't matter I guess yeah you
just have to watch the movie yeah and at
one point he gets her a thing where he
can like take her with him yeah it's
Colin mu it was an emulator emulator
yeah because before she was kind of
stuck in his apartment because of the
hologram thing yeah yeah she had to be
projected from the ceiling ceiling but
then he bought this special thing with
his bonus that allowed him to take her
outside she ever been outside that's a
really cool part but yeah like I said I
think that's kind of the heart of the
movie because it's show he's like yeah
he's not a real person and she's not a
real person but they do seem to have
genuine love for each other yeah I guess
they do and so I think that's kind of
the Metta statement that the movie is
making is that when they've gotten to
this point when you've got to this point
in artificial intelligence it doesn't
matter
that they're not hero that they weren't
born or anything like that right it's
like you know they are still just as
real as we they feel the same emotions
and things of that nature and I think
that's kind of what it's getting at so I
like that they have that relationship at
the heart of it as sort of a parallel of
the human Android type thing that they
have going on as well it's definitely a
good movie yeah it's a it's a worthy
successor to the original this is a
bonafide science fiction film unlike
some of the other dribble dribble that's
come out recently this is one that you
know I recommend buying on blu-ray if
you're a sci-fi yeah I mean if you miss
it in the theater I feel sorry for you
because yeah this is what it was like
Mad Max barrier Ripper you really had to
see it in the theater to go wrong I mean
it's still beautiful on blu-ray like on
a big-screen TV and stuff but yeah in
the theater it was like yeah it was a
mind-blowing
yes it was I can't believe I can't
believe it didn't do all that well
should have done twice that it should
have yeah it's just I think it's gonna
be like Blade Runner and Mad Max 1 or
Mad Max 2 road warrior over time
I'm sure his first Blade Runner was not
successful no theater either no it
really didn't build up seem until later
on when it became a classic this I think
it will follow the same route it'll
definitely be it'll definitely be around
for a long time oh yeah yes and I
definitely like I said it's it's already
won tons and tons of awards it's just
pretty much I think it's eighty nine
ninety five percent yeah of critical
reviews are positive
oh I okay I was reading an article about
this movie in The New Yorker this is
gonna blow your mind
okay I think all right okay you know the
part where kay is being given like every
time he had you know he has to do his
job and stuff and he has to do that
calibration test or whatever the
post-traumatic elation and he's like
saying all that stuff like interlinked
interlinked yes cells within cells yeah
okay do you know where that's from
no okay do you remember the part where
him and joy are in the apartment and she
picks up the delorca am i talking it's
from there okay
yes yes so that does have some
significance when they showed that book
twice and I said there's something about
that book yeah and well that's where
that whole within cells at your
lengthens oh yeah that's where that
comes from that comes from that book
guys haven't seen it seen the movie
every time he retires a replica he's got
to go back to a police station and they
put him in this little cell and then
they ask him a bunch of weird
interlocking questions that are meant to
like evoke emotion and they're trying to
find out what his emotional baseline is
yeah because they don't want him to get
so emotional that they can't control him
anymore and I guess they kill him you
know so he's got to go through this
ritual it's weird what you see it yeah
oh and can I also shout out the woman
that plays love in this yeah she is
[ __ ] awesome yes [ __ ] yeah she's
weird she looks she's very pretty very
almost kind of artificial looking yeah
well she is a replicant yeah and she
seems like a replica yeah in the movie
which is really freaky yeah but she's um
she's actually Wallis's you know the CEO
of the Wallace corporation he's played
by Jared Leto she's like his right-hand
man rut right-hand woman right she's
extremely strong she can kill you with
her bare hands
yeah little bitty thing yeah but she's
fast strong yeah and her name is love
and she's kind of the one that's kind of
tracking Kay like on his mission and
stuff like that and she she's a
frightening woman yeah she's kind of
like his personal James Bond yeah that
kind of a soldier a detective all kind
of wrapped into one and then she'll kill
a human being just without even thinking
about it
yeah but yeah she's uh kind of quite I
see yeah she was really a standout for
me and this her and the actress that
played joy the hologram fantastic face -
oh yeah great great yes and she and just
the way she moves her clothes she always
looks very perfect yeah like a fashion
model in a way yeah but just her on
everything movements her facial
expressions her voice like everything
about her she seems very artificial and
it's like it's an amazing amazing job
actually really everybody was amazing it
there is no there's no bad acting in it
no there's really not it's everybody
it's just perfect and Harrison Ford did
a pretty good job of bringing Deckard
back yeah I couldn't find any problems
with it I mean I went back over the
movie and tried to be critical of it to
find problems I have to be I had to
really turn to turn my [ __ ] level up
to like a yeah before I could really
find any problems with this movie I
really could not I mean this movie which
just it blew me away in the theater yeah
and then the second time I saw it I got
way more into like the whole emotional
core are full of philosophical questions
and everything like that it's just a
it's got a really a gorgeous movie they
make a lot of movies like I'm gonna say
nowadays probably this movie will appeal
to the 30-plus crowd probably more than
the young problem and like I said I mean
if we like the original Blade Runner
yeah you're young you'll love this one
too yeah it's a similar theme right and
really like it's it's totally a worthy
successor I was worried about it when I
first heard that they were making a
sequel to the original Blade Runner I
was kind of like you know I was saying
like that I was like oh it's gonna suck
and stuff like that but this I mean this
way way way exceeded my ex-husband guard
kind of detective story that's what the
original was like yeah and then this one
is very much like I said it's not even
it's not really a reboot it's an
expansion yeah the world is bigger the
questions are bigger so it just it takes
it to its logical conclusion which I
really really like and I really like
that they did and it looks just as good
it looks different of course because of
modern technology and CG you can make a
world appear a lot bigger than yeah than
it did in blatant the first plate rotor
but still it kind of carried on that
same tradition yeah because one thing
about the first Blade Runner movie is
that it felt real to me when they would
pick something up at look what was it
was a real object yeah and the things
that they were like the cars and the
computers and the things of it you could
tell it they were well used yeah broken
and dirty looking then yeah there was
garbage on the ground you know there
just rain everywhere and it just gave a
good atmosphere of like you were looking
at a real place yeah you know this one -
this one has that
feel and like I said it seems like a
logical because you know in the first
Blade Runner you have particular
technologies and stuff and now in this
one which is set thirty years later
people use some of the same technologies
but there are some improvements and some
new ones may be not that great but it
seems like a realistic yeah progression
yeah the first budget was a lot bigger
and the special effects are a lot better
today so they were able to take you into
other places around Los Angeles that
that the first movie couldn't couldn't
show you yeah like they take you to the
dump
yeah an adult i Gannicus got oil tankers
in it yeah you know pretty neat also got
to say Lennie James has a very small
part of the German that if you're a fan
of The Walking Dead yes we are you plays
Morgan otherwise yeah he is he has a
very small role in this also very good
yeah like I said everybody in this is
good yeah and it's it's just really
really good and if you haven't seen it
like I said if you're into intellectual
type sci-fi yea then this is problem
then this is yeah and if you're a fan of
the original bladder you haven't seen
this yet you really need to you really
and I think you I think it's for rent
right now probably on YouTube or maybe
Amazon you could probably rent it
downloaded yeah although like I said you
should have really seen it for the month
for them yeah I'm just I'm wagging my
finger it's for the money I get the
money I get the blu-ray that's what I
did yeah cuz it's really really gorgeous
yeah so and that blu-ray wasn't cheap I
think I think 30 bucks for that blu-ray
but worth it oh yes going into
collections and actually now that we
know that we're talking about I kind of
want it it's getting the same thing as
like Mad Max fury road burr it's just
like it seems like one of those movies
yeah that I'm gonna be able to watch
over and over and never get tired of yes
I have the same thing with the shining
cuz we bought the shining on blu-ray to
just the other day and we watched it
that even though I probably seen that
movie 20 25 times and I was like this is
one of those movies that I never get
sick oh I did watched it every day
so you bagged it on me about Star Wars
but I tell you up for 2017 I was checked
for two movies the last Jedi and this
Blade Runner movie Blade Runner made up
for my disappointment in stores well now
I'm really holding out for fur sauce
solo
yeah solo movie I kind of after last gen
I'm like minutes
suck but while I'm holding out for is
Ron Howard maybe Ron Howard and save it
let me guess look how good robot was
right again was yeah yeah everyone
actually so if it's the same kind of
deal is that right I'm gonna go into it
like it sucks well that's kind of a good
thing do you want any move because I
waited a Blade Runner like this shit's
gonna suck yeah remember that I'm saying
that you know watching it and like we're
more than halfway through it I got this
[ __ ] man this is awesome
I know it's like I was just like oh the
whole time I was just like looking up at
the screen oh my god yeah okay and Ron
Howard man who you know do what you
gotta do Ron Howard come on then don't
let me down happens I'm through with
Star Wars game at all oh he's so butter
okay so that'll do it for this review
slash recommendation go see flavor
20:49 it's really really awesome yeah
and if you like the show and you would
like to support it remember to check us
out on patreon or Jan or blog and share
share with your friends yeah share on
all your social media and share and
sharing a lake it's a it's fun for
everyone right they wanna win situation
and keep an eye out for our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday and our
movie reviews which usually come out
every Friday and that'll do it for this
episode see you next time bye